to a story you will only see from our 8
news now investigators a man filing a
lawsuit against a strip Casino accusing
security cards there of not doing enough
before a gunman shot him eight news now
investigator David charns breaking the
story first inside of our free app so
David what's this man saying well he is
accusing staff at the Venetian of
failing to protect him and the group he
was with after a man allegedly
threatened him with a gun that all
happening on the casino floor now things
then escalated outside now this shooting
victim is recovering from his injuries
the lawsuit filed Thursday accuses the
Venetian and its security staff of
failing to protect a group of customers
after a man threatened them with a gun
documents say that man later shot Eric
Aguilar as he was celebrating his
birthday according to the lawsuit and
court documents in January 2021 that
gunman shot Aguilar outside of the
Palazzo on the Las Vegas Strip following
an altercation inside lawyer is writing
without warning the gunman began to
verbally engage Mr Aguilar's group
stating that he would expletive kill Mr
Aguilar and his friends the lawsuit says
the man with the gun then left the
casino after making the threat security
guards then evicting Aguilar and his
friends from the property lawyers
writing upon hearing Mr Aguilar report
that the gunman had threatened him with
a handgun on the gaming floor one of the
three uniform security guards said they
did not give an expletive that the
gunman had pointed a gun at him and told
Mr Aguilar to leave but it's what
happened outside that lawyers say
changed Aguilar's life forever Aguilar
left a casino and was walking on the
sidewalk with a friend when the alleged
gunman greeted them police alleging
Aguilar in his group then hit the armed
man and his friend with beer bottles
Aguilar's attorneys say it was
self-defense the gunman then shot
Aguilar on the sidewalk the lawsuit
claiming the casino was negligent by not
taking care of the alleged gunman sooner
which led to that shooting outside now a
grand jury indicted Aguilar the shooting
victim on charges connecting to the
fight outside the casino that you just
saw he has pleaded not guilty saying
that it was self-defense since he knew
that that man who would shoot him just
seconds later had a gun since he showed
him that on the casino floor we tried to
get more information about the gunmen
but Metro Police declined to release an
incident report today citing an ongoing
investigation Denise so David as you
mentioned it's important to note that
Firearms are banned on the Venetian
property excluding the on-duty law
enforcement that's according to a post
which is right on its website we did ask
representatives from the Venetian for
comment on this lawsuit today ended not
to